someone made a literally unbeatable ship
in stallfield by basically making it out
of Corners apparently enemies will only
target the center of the ship so if you
get into combat in a ship that looks
like this where it's just a bunch of
Corners they will never actually be able
to hit you this is for more follow he
only has 97 subscribers so I'm going to
leave a link in the comments so maybe we
can get him to I don't know at least a
few hundred this blew up on the
Starfield subreddit but then he's
uploaded a full walkthrough of the ship
which is ridiculous looking to his
YouTube channel people have taken this
even a step further Now by completely
getting rid of shields because you don't
need them and just putting everything
into weapons so that you're making just
like an invincible killing machine I
hope I personally open up patch it
because it's hilarious